[Music]  PGs drops their official collaboration  with steve aoki the kpop fan debuted a  Okies remix of mike drop on friday along  with a flashy music video check out  their insane dance moves and their  english the remix quickly rose to the  top of the charts making BTS the first  k-pop group to hit number one on the US  iTunes top songs meanwhile the hashtag  Mike drop remix has been trending on  Twitter the original version of the song  was released on the group's new album  love yourself her back in September et  caught up with the boys in LA last week  here's what they teased about their  upcoming world tour so for sure we will  visit I think more cities and I think  will definitely be like you know like  adding like more performance and more  stages so I don't know like the this  particular time when we'll be coming  back but you know but it's definitely  gonna be like doper and it's gonna have  her yeah it really happen  [Music]  you